[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Geospatial
insights can help
your organization realize a
more prosperous and sustainable
future.
Want to see how?
Let's take a look at
Google Earth Engine,
a powerful platform
that makes uncovering
these valuable
insights possible.
Earth Engine was launched
over a decade ago
as a geospatial
analytics platform
that takes planet scale data--
and I mean that literally
and figuratively--
and couples it with
the computing power
of Google's infrastructure.
Researchers, scientists,
and developers
alike have been driving
impact across sectors
by detecting and qualifying
changes, mapping global trends,
and more.
Consider a research team who
used Earth Engine to build
an innovative monitoring
and alerting tool
to protect against
illegal logging.
So how might that
relate to your work?
Let's dig in.
We're excited to now provide
limited commercial availability
of Earth Engine so data and
geospatial professionals,
like you, can accelerate
impact within your own business
and augment the
impact-driven work being
done every day by the vibrant
community of Earth Engine
users.
Here are three
things for you to put
in your mental map for how
Earth Engine can help you
on your team--
the data catalog,
development flexibility,
and common business drivers.
First, the data.
Living up to Google's
mission, that
is, to organize the
world's information
and make it more
accessible and useful,
we've cataloged
over 50 petabytes
of analysis-ready data about
the Earth's present, past,
and future.
This includes climate
and weather data,
imagery from satellite platforms
such as Landsat, Sentinel,
and MODIS, and other
geophysical data,
like terrain and land cover
maps in both raster and vector
formats.
Time series data stretches back
over 40 years in some cases.
And on the other
hand of the clock,
there are many
real-time data sets too.
The increasing volume
of satellite launches
with ever more
sophisticated sensors
is helping fuel an explosion
of fresh, high frequency Earth
observation data as well.
So that means more and more
data becoming available,
along with the
need for platforms
to be able to ingest, store,
and process them efficiently.
Fortunately, this
is something Google
and Earth Engine are
equipped to handle at scale.
What that means
is that users like
you get to focus on
just the fun stuff--
geospatial analytics
and data science.
Accessing the data
in Earth Engine
is as simple as a
few lines of code.
So bring your hypotheses, know
the extent of your analysis
and time horizon, and
you're ready to go.
Second, consider the flexibility
of the development environment.
Earth Engine has a
computational engine
that can handle the
complexity and global scale
that thousands of PhDs,
developers, and data scientists
throw at it every day.
There are several options
for you to access and work
with the data that takes
advantage of that computing
power.
You can connect to the
Earth Engine service
through one of its APIs.
Client libraries for
JavaScript and Python
translate complex
geospatial analyses
into Earth Engine requests.
Or connect directly to
Earth Engine servers
using the REST API.
Earth Engine also provides
an interactive environment
with an online code editor,
ideal for prototyping
and iteration.
More comfortable in Python?
Earth Engine also works in
Python notebooks like Colab.
You can even run
inference directly
from satellite
images using Cloud AI
Platform from Earth Engine.
And the results
are returned to you
as an image or set of features
right in Earth Engine.
That's cool, right?
When you're ready
to go global scale,
you can take advantage of
Earth Engine's batch mode
to process petabytes of data
within a massively parallelized
environment with zero
configuration or server
management.
To create interactive
experiences of your analyses
that can be securely
shared with your users,
you can use Earth Engine
apps with its library of UI
components and hosted platform.
Finally, there are a handful
of common business drivers
that you or maybe someone
else in your organization
are thinking about already.
Vexing questions,
like how resilient
is my business to effects
from climate change?
How or is my
business compounding
economic and societal
issues around deforestation
or pollution?
Or what else can I do to support
our ESG reporting initiatives?
There are common themes we see
across commercial applications.
One, for example, is
using climate data
to understand risk or
impacts to physical assets
like infrastructure or
real estate holdings
across disparate geographies.
Beyond assessing risk, there
are many other use cases
to spark your creativity too.
OK, we've covered a
lot about Earth Engine,
and there's so much more
for you to check out.
Head on over to our website
where you can explore the data
catalog, read through a few
case studies as inspiration,
and register your
team's interest
in accessing Earth
Engine during preview.
We can't wait to hear about
the initiatives you all
will be driving, and the
combined impact we can make
together with Google Earth
Engine for creating prosperity,
resilience, and sustainability
for your organization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]